bonjour bienvenue dans point de vue
quatre invités 40 minutes de débat sur
l'actualité c'est la formule de
l'émission est une forme plutôt gagnante
puisque vous êtes toujours plus nombreux
à nous suivre alors continuez comme cela
l'actualité ce soir c'est la grogne des
maires réunis en congrès la
calinothérapie d'edouard philippe
aujourd'hui et d' emmanuel macron jeudi
peut-elle les calmer on va en parler
nous parlerons aussi des contes du front
national la société générale vient de
fermer le robinet du crédit au parti de
marine le pen et ça fait beaucoup réagir
autre sujet qui ne laisse pas
indifférent ce stage hallucinant
organisée par le syndicat sud
stage au cours duquel les profs seront
triés selon qu'ils sont blancs ou pas
et enfin dernier thème pour la route si
je puis dire puisqu'il s'agit des
voitures dans paris une fois de plus la
mère anne hidalgo en prend pour son
grade
bonjour à tous les quatre bonjour lucie
limite à longeau vous êtes co présidente
de la fondation verte européenne vous
avez été conseiller régional
ile-de-france au ps avant de rejoindre
europe écologie et vous est aussi
l'auteur de la france résiste-t-elle à
l'écologie paru aux éditions le bord de
l'eau en 2016 l'écologie la politique
locale on va en parler
laurent dandrieu bonjour bienvenue sur
ce plateau vous êtes rédacteur en chef
adjoint du service société à valeurs
actuelles est également responsable de
la rubrique débats opinion de
l'hebdomadaire donc plus du tout cette
culture avec vous et rédacteur en chef
du web alors on rectifie tout de suite
et vous est aussi l'auteur de église et
immigration le grand malaise c'est paru
aux presses de la renaissance cette
année bonjour bonjour jean marc four
dont je lenteur de la rédaction de
france inter france inter dont on salue
les bonnes audiences confirmées la
semaine dernière par médiamétrie et vous
êtes-vous l'auteur de la mécanique
médiatique c'était aux éditions le mieux
en février 2016 bonjour jean marc
bonjour marc aujourd'hui rédacteur en
chef du service économie france du
figaro spécialiste de l'économie mais
dont la
il est pertinent surtout on va parler
des finances locales du front national
et des banques des syndicats de profs
cette émission est faite pour vous
marquez alors avant de commencer un mot
sur le remaniement attendu
le suspense continue christophe castaner
gardera-t-il son poste de secrétaire
d'état aux relations avec le parlement
on attend l'annoncé d'un instant à
l'autre mais bien entendu on vous le
dira si ça intervient pendant l'émission
les maires de france maintenant alors
sont-ils les bonnes à tout faire de la
république
en tout cas c'est une opération déminage
que lance emmanuel macron et son premier
ministre
ils savent que les maires de france
réuni à paris pour leur 100ème congrès
sont en colère ils ont bien senti le
danger de cette grogne qui monte des
territoires c'est en effet devenu le
principal cheval de bataille de
l'opposition
chez les républicains la maire de calais
natacha bouchart et le sénateur bruno
retailleau sont montés au front on les
écoute que marie pas fait que ainsi que
que pour paille c'est tout est concentré
sur paris non parce que tout ça car on
va revenir tout savoir c'est paris et
toutes les autres communes de france
on s'en fout et on ne discute pas on
nous impose des des régimes drastiques
monsieur macron un problème avec les
territoires
quand il dit qu'il ya trop d'élus il
sait pas que les élus locaux 90%
évolution des bénévoles et qu'on a
besoin d'eux parce que tout que ne
résout pas paris c'est eux les maires je
vais vous dire aujourd'hui ils sont
devenus les bonnes à tout faire de la
république sans les maires ya pas de
france lé 6 8 vous avez été élu
municipal
il a raison une retailleau c'est les
bonnes à tout faire d'un public ce qui
est sûr c'est que c'est un échelon de
proximité les mères c'est à dire
qu'effectivement
y compris dans les communes de la petite
couronne on connaît son maire on sait à
qui s'adresser et en période de
difficultés sociales
c'est plus souvent au maire co président
de la république qu'on écrit pour
demander un logement ou un emploi est ce
que ça veut dire pour autant qu'on ait
une bonne à tout faire ça je n'en sais
rien et le sujet c'est qu'il ya à la
fois des maires des conseillers
régionaux vous le rappeliez j'ai été
conseillère régionale des conseillers
départementaux et aujourd'hui un mille
feuille territorial qui fait qu' on ne
sait plus très bien lorsqu'on est
citoyen habitant d'une ville comment s'y
retrouver
donc il ya sûrement un sujet de
rationalisation après c'est vrai que
traiter les élus locaux par le mépris
c'est prendre le risque de donner aux
citoyens le fait le sentiment qu'on les
traite également par le mépris
ils sont traités par le mépris jean marc
four les élus locaux la haine de la
province comme leurs proches laurent
wauquiez à gaza c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça alors il ya risque
politique c'est évident effectivement
parce que les élus de proximité sont
populaires et assez légitimement parce
que c'est l'interlocuteur de proximité
donc c'est légitime et donc il ya un
risque politique je suis d'accord là où
la situation est un peu plus compliqué
c'est que en fait si on va dans le
détail qu'on discute avec les élus
locaux
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya aussi des
d'aborder les postures politiques
premièrement et deuxièmement plutôt que
d'opposer par exemple comme le faisait
ma bouche à la paris et le reste de la
france
la différence aujourd'hui est plutôt
entre les grandes villes on va dire où
les grandes intercommunalités et les
communes plus petites puisque d'ailleurs
jean luc moudenc
mais les républicains de toulouse donc a
priori dans l'opposition le reconnaît il
y a aujourd'hui un travail plutôt
positif de tentatives de
contractualisation entre l'état et les
municipalités les plus importantes
donc je pense qu'il faut descendre un
petit peu dans l'arborescence pour bien
comprendre la difficulté qui réellement
pour un certain nombre de connexions
les grandes villes contre les boues les
jo je crois qu'effectivement le problème
de l'effort qu'on demande actuellement
au maire c'est de mettre un peu tout le
monde dans le même panier au risque de
pénaliser les plus petites communes qui
ne paraissent pas responsable de manière
prioritaire des dérapages budgétaires
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui en france et
qui sont objectivement très utile au
maillage social des territoires et et au
maintien d'une certaine vie dans les
provinces françaises
on a l'impression que ce sont des
réformes qui sont décidés de très très
haut sans vrai et le souci de la réalité
du terrain alors trois défenses des
mères marc landré vous lever le sourcil
il ya des économies à faire un gâteau
ah oui les économies à faire les
économies qui sont faire depuis des
années et pour pour un petit peu aller
plus loin que ce que ce que vous disiez
les économies qui sont demandé
aujourd'hui aux mères elles vont être
faits uniquement dans les grandes
communes les petits doit être totalement
épargnée puisque grosso modo là où avant
la mue de l'exécutif précédent disait
ont baissé dotation de tout le monde et
après vous vous démerdez là
effectivement emmanuel macron fait
différemment et contractualiser avec les
319 plus grand territoire plus grandes
collectivités de france il redit voilà
moi je dis là avec vous parce que vous
vous représentez le grand amour qu'on
raconte alain lassus alisation on accule
marie-amélie une contractualisation
319 collectivités qui représentent 80%
des dépenses de fonctionnement des
communes des régions et des départements
de kid ordinn il ya 13 milliards
d'économies à faire jeudi avec vous les
autres je vous laisse tranquille donc en
vérité les petites communes elles vont
en rien panier de mal sur les demandes
économies elles s'en sortent pas si mal
en revanche elles sont touchées sur les
baisses des apl puisque effectivement
raison des logements à pourvoir et clé
avec des gens qui vont toucher un petit
peu moins elles seront touchés sur la
baisse des contrats aidés puisque on ne
va quand même avoir du nez sous l'eau
est une division par deux du volume de
contrats aidés en circulation il faut se
rappeler qu'il ya encore un an
l'exécutif précédent on disait aux
maires et aux dit aux responsables de
collectivités recrutent et des contrats
aidés parce que ça va faire baisser le
chômage
aujourd'hui on leur dit le contraire
finalement vous coupent vos coupe
l'herbe sous le pied on vous enlève on
coupe le robinet et vous pouvez pu
souscrire de contrats aidés donc le
problème pour les petites communes et
surtout là il est sur les contrats aidés
et sur les appels plus que sur les
efforts d'économies à faire même s'il ya
des gramounes
alors je reviens sur un terrain plus
politique otc il ya plus de cumul des
mandats on a plus de sénateur maire
député maire est-ce que du coup les
grandes gueules j'allais dire ne joue
pas la carte du justement de
l'opposition ils sont merde et que
jean-marc là dessus c'est prenant
prenons les leaders politiques prenons
les grandes gueules comme vous dites est
alors écoutons par exemple ce que disait
françois fillon n'y a pas si longtemps
en disant il faut pas trente six mille
inconnues commune il n'en faut sept
mille et si j'étais président je
passerai de 36000 communes à 7000 ça
c'est assez radical il avait même
envisagé je crois si ma mémoire ne me
trahit pas de soumettre cette idée au
référendum
donc j'ai des idées radicales et
autrement plus radicale il y en a déjà
eu un certain nombre sur ce sujet parce
qu'on s'est quand même
alors là j'en reviens aux petites
communes on sait quand même qu'il ya
certes de petites communes je crois que
c'est une s'offrira une commune sur deux
donc à peu près 17 18 mille en france la
moitié des 35 ou 36 mille et une commune
de moins de 500 habitants je crois que
c'est ça donc c'est tout petit et c'est
vrai que c'est une ça pose des
difficultés pour négocier un certain
nombre de choses c'est pour ça qu'on
crée des intercommunalités aussi parce
que parce que les toutes petites entités
aujourd'hui elles ont des difficultés
des difficultés de personnel mais des
difficultés de passer des contrats à des
tarifs qui soit on va dire acceptable
donc enfin tout ça pour dire quoi que il
faut se méfier des postures là je
reviens à mon idée de départ parce que
je pense que c'est le sujet est complexe
oui l idée technique est ce que est ce
qu'ils ont raison finalement les
républicains de prendre ce cheval de
bataille georges andrieu fier des
postures il faut se méfier méfier aussi
des idées générales c'est à dire il ya
trop de communes c'est typiquement une
caravane de bataille je pense que c'est
un bon cheval de bataille pour les gens
qui ont le souci de l'intérêt des
français
c'est qu'effectivement les gens sur la
tâche mais est-ce que ça risque pas de
leur revenir en boomerang que ce que
disait jean marc même vous avait prôné
les manières communalité des économies
et aujourd'hui après ne sont pas liés
par le programme de françois fillon peut
considérer qu'il ya aujourd'hui des
grands-mères de gauche c'est à dire que
autant la bouche a été décimée aux
élections législatives autant elle reste
présente dans les territoires et ça ça
mon avis la distinction gauche droite
elle va pas de soi et la deuxième chose
que je voulais dire moi par rapport à ce
que vous disiez marque c'est que il ya
certes des petites et des grandes
communes et les petites communes sont
épargnés mais parce que les petites
communes sont déjà davantage en
difficulté elles ont pas la force de
frappe en termes de négociations
financières en termes de prise
d'initiative on voit bien comment anne
hidalgo prend la tête de la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique
elles sont pas les grandes communes et a
fortiori les métropoles dans une
relation de dépendance à la
contractualisation que vous évoquez et
marie-amélie donc je pense que c'est
normal que les petites communes soit
épargné parce qu'elles sont déjà en
difficulté
oui mais on était mois l'os avant c'est
à dire qu'il ya un sujet sur quand on
est à l'os qui est ce qu'on épargne
parce que de toute façon sinon on tue le
malade ça veut dire que découlant du
gouvernement et couleur politique et a
fondé ce que je voulais dire c'est que
l'autre chose par rapport à ce qu'on
évoque sais que c'est difficile de
dissocier la question des communes de
celle des autres aux échelons
territoriaux ce qui a été évoqué
d'ailleurs par lan ou l'autre et la
question c'est est ce qu'à un moment on
supprime un échelon alors françois
fillon avait proposé de mettre sept
mille communes parce qu'ils osaient pas
proposé supprimée le département donc il
ya un débat qui dure depuis maintenant
25 ans sur est-ce qu'on supprime
l'échelon départemental
mais c'est l'échelon historique et qui
s'occupe des questions sociales donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport au fait
qu'on est aujourd'hui dans un moment
d'inégalités sociales important on
rajoute on rajoute de la complexité je
dirais que c'est pas qu'on sait rien je
pense qu'on rajoute de la complexité sur
le cul de cumuler 10 échelons
territoriaux nahon razida cumul avec la
mettre dedans mémoire de mémoire d'un
sous l'ancien exécutif au départ on
devait supprimer le niveau des
départements
oui après comme ça a râlé on a le ballon
finalement on va inciter les
départements à fusionner et au final il
reste quoi il ya du avoir peut-être
trois quatre départements confusionnel
et c'est quasiment installé on a rajouté
les métropoles
paul mais juste pour préciser une chose
par rapport aux dépenses il faut bien
s'il faut bien savoir une chose c'est
que on a une croissance de la masse
salariale dans les communes depuis 25
ans il ya eu certes un transfert de
compétences de la part de l'état au
niveau des communes au fond au niveau
des niveaux infra et notamment au niveau
des communes mais savez-vous que 60% des
hausses de dépenses des communes sont
liées à des décisions communales pas des
décisions d'état c'est pas parce qu'on a
revalorisé le point d'indicé des
fonctionnaires qui pèse pour 40% dans la
hausse de la masse salariale dans les
communes en vérité la ou les
la principale explication pour 60% des
hausses des dépenses de personnel c'est
les journées du maire qui sont rajoutés
c'est les augmentations les primes au
niveau local et c'est ça qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il ya du grain à moudre
au niveau communal pour faire des
économies
parce que vous avez dans une ville comme
montpellier ou toulouse
vous avez des gens qui travaillent moins
de 35 heures par semaine qui ont des
semaines à rallonge de congés payés en
plus offert par les municipalités qui
font qu'il ya vraiment un niveau de
dépense qui est beaucoup plus élevé par
rapport à la moyenne et donc les
économies elles sont avant tout des
contrats et des connaissances de cause
donc toutes ces deux là où il ya du
graal voilà ce qu'il faut regarder au
cas villa en tiennent d'ailleurs en tout
cas ce qui était intéressant
effectivement pendant la campagne de
macron c'est qu'il a rapproché la
question des économies publiques de
celle des collectivités locales c'est à
dire que c'est vrai on a beaucoup parlé
des fonctionnaires de l'administration
d'état et peu des fonctionnaires des
collectivités locales et à fortiori
communal après le dossier est compliqué
on va le dire franchement sur ce plateau
parce que quelque part il ya une
relation de proximité aussi entre le
personnel et le maire qui existe est
donc cette proximité elle renforce des
liens qui sont parfois des liens de
nature je vais pas dire qu'ils sont
électoraux mais en tout cas la proximité
existe sur le vol est presque dire
qu'ils ont une liste non je ne vais pas
le dire mais je pense que c'est plus
compliqué que ça pour avoir été élu
local c'est des liens de proximité qui
effectivement sont très forts qu'ils
sont humains qui peuvent être parfois
clientéliste tout à fait dans notre
tribu tion d'un logement ou d'un emploi
ça existe
après la question c'est que justement
dans une transition comme celle là ça se
fait pas du jour au lendemain il s'est
pas seulement des économies
r il ya un élément humain qui le
resteront le sujet fait réagir je vous
livre quelques unes des réflexions de
nos internautes flou qui nous dit on
devrait couper les budgets de l'état et
des dirigeants avant de s'attaquer au
budget des communes
c'est radical raul beaucoup de blabla
pour pas grand chose les maires font un
super boulot mais à mon avis ils sont
trop vulnérables financièrement et
dominique qui estime qu'en agissant
ainsi le gouvernement veut sans doute la
mort des petites communes elle ce
robuste se rassembler si ce n'est déjà
fait donc effectivement la tonalité
plutôt à la défense des maires au nab
son maire et pourtant et pourtant il y
avait une information en préparant la
mission je voyais que six français sur
dix se disent satisfaits de leur mère
mais ils ne sont qu'un sur deux à
pouvoir citer son nom évidemment plus
facilement dans les petites communes que
dans les grandes et les maires des
communes rurales soient mieux connus de
leurs administrés enfin bon il ya toute
cette proximité que vous évoquez les uns
les autres on va parler maintenant du
front national les décomptes du front
national puisque la société générale
c'est une information révélée par france
inter jean marc four la société générale
a demandé au front national
deux clôturé ses comptes sans révéler
d'ailleurs les raisons qui poussent la
banque à akoupé ainsi les crédits alors
est ce une simple mesure de gestion
bancaire ou une atteinte à l'exercice
démocratique
vous allez nous donner vos points de vue
mais on regarde d'abord la réaction de
david rachline le responsable de la
communication nationale notre relation
aux banques est un des grands scandales
démocratique de notre temps déjà allé au
moment de l'élection présidentielle nous
étions recherche d'argent recherche de
près pour pouvoir mener campagne et
l'intégralité des banques françaises
avait refusé de nous prêter un seul
centime les banques et certains ne
membre de l'oligarchie sans doute se
servent c'était dollars ça veut dire
quoi membres de l'auberge de leur
pouvoir il ya aussi se servent de leurs
pouvoirs financiers pour faire en sorte
que certains mouvements politiques ne
puissent pas faire campagne
laurent dandrieu après tout elle a
raison la sûreté générale le feb le fn
c'est un client comme un autre et si
elle veut
je pense qu'à partir de ce type là ne
peut pas être accueilli comme un autre
dans la mesure où il participe à la vie
démocratique du pays et donc c'est
difficile de dire comme ça sans
justification vous arrêtez d'être client
chez nous alors qu'effectivement on
estime par ailleurs que les partis
politiques sont nécessaires à la vie
démocratique
on ne peut pas dire à mon avis il est
impossible de soutenir que ce soit une
pure mesure technique dans la mesure où
effectivement il ya le contexte qui fait
qu'on l'a reproché au front national
aller chercher des emprunts à l'étranger
mais s'il était contraint d'aller
chercher saison de prêt à l'étranger
c'est parce qu'ils n'entreraient pas en
france dont il ya un vrai problème de
fermeture vis-à-vis du système bancaire
français vis-à-vis du front national qui
de fait n'est pas traitée par le système
bancaire français comme un parti comme
les autres
quelle est la vraie une vraie un vrai
sujet je ne suis pas spécialiste des
comptes fera sien mais il ya quelque
chose parce que la société générale
était de la banque du front national
depuis des dizaines d'années nous dit on
et en même temps effectivement c'est
fait partie des leitmotivs du front
national de 10 les banques françaises ne
nous accorde pas de credit ça donc sk
pas un peu d'astuce dans le jama vous
qui avez vu la question de près il y en
a un ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
cette histoire en fait dure depuis
plusieurs mois elle a débuté dans les
médias d'après législatives où
apparemment la société générale a
commencé à se poser des questions sur le
maintien de ses comptes du front
national c'est non seulement nationale
mais délibération il y a eu semble-t-il
une série des changes si vous voulez
entre se tait général et le front
national depuis le mois de juillet sur
cette série des changes qui a été
déclenchée par le fait que la société
générale souhaitait arrêter et
que le front national souhaitait
continuer je résume mais c'est à peu
près ça etc autant qu'on puisse le
savoir il semblerait malgré tout que la
société générale ait des doutes sur la
capacité du fn d'une part à rembourser
ensemble d'emprunt et d'autres pas et
les doutes sur je dis bien et des doutes
moi je n'ai je n'ai pas de preuves bien
évidemment mais et des doutes sur la
propreté de
certains tracés de mouvement dans les
comptes ont levé hall des arts de oui
c'est un virage tracks fin mais je vois
là je sais c'est en tout cas ce qui
semblerait avoir motivé cette décision
-peut-être il semblerait après je suis
d'accord on peut pas très démocratique
même s'il vient parce qu'effectivement
il ya un enjeu démocratique il doit il
doit s'exercer aussi pour le front
national et donc doit presse nationale
n'y a pas à discriminer le front
national par rapport aux autres partis
politiques
après ayant appartenu maintenant je n'y
apporte un plus mais un petit parti
politique ayant des difficultés
financières qui s'appelle europe
ecologie les verts
je peux vous dire qu'on avait avec la
banque des discussions qui étaient tout
à fait technique et qui était tout à
fait financière c'est à dire que le
front national n'est pas discriminer à
mon sens par rapport à ce qui est le
problème des grands partis ayant
beaucoup d'argent et de ceux qui ont
plus de difficultés c'est peut-être
redoublé parce que c'est un parti
effectivement qui est un parti d'extrême
droite mais en tout cas avoir des
discussions financières techniques et
avoir le sentiment qu'on n'arrivera pas
à se faire prêter de l'argent moi je les
ai vécus dans un autre parti politique
donc c'est pas propre à l'aï travers ces
actions du front national ce n'était pas
une persécution et quand on est un petit
parti on a beaucoup plus de difficultés
avec sa banque quand on est quand on
était le parti socialiste où les
républicains quand on était
effectivement ce que disait marc landré
vous qui êtes un homme de chiffres c'est
quoi alors là se tenir à la raison tort
on connaît pas ses motivations comme l'a
dit jean marc est ce que c'est pour des
questions bancaires est ce que c'est
pour les questions de principe et de
morale si c'est pour des questions
bancaires il faut que le motive pourquoi
elle tenait aussi généralement avec un
client content j'ai prolongé qu'un
disant qu'ils sont c'est-à-dire est un
enjeu politique publique maintenant oui
si c'est un enjeu politique si c'est un
enjeu c'est un enjeu purement financier
de comptes de respectabilité des comptes
c'est un regarde la banque et le parti
en tout cas son client en revanche et
c'est une question morale une question
politique ça pose d'autres questions
jeudi reçoit le fn est un parti comme
les autres et dans ce cas il a le droit
d'avoir un compte en banque il a droit
d'avoir des financements il rate se
présenter aux élections et droite d'être
au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle faut-il le rappeler
et dans ce cas là il n'ya pas le
discriminé par rapport à un autre soit
on l'interdît
on considère qu'il est dangereux pour la
démocratie il appellera d'avoir du comté
pourra se présenter aux élections etc et
ses stars mais comme on ne sait pas si
c'est un enjeu politique ou en enjeu
comptable c'est compliqué c'est
difficile de lui ce qui est intéressant
c'est ce que vous ne disiez sur le fait
que ça dure depuis des mois en fait
après les élections législatives qui a
eu un échange qui n'était pas connu du
grand public il ya une accélération et
un débat qui s'ouvre juste après les
lesparrains d'aspect peu c'est à dire
que la question de tracfin est une
question très importante on est
aujourd'hui dans un moment où on
découvre progressivement de l'évasion
fiscale du blanchiment et c est donc il
ya peut-être aussi une actualité qui
fait que du côté de la banque qui est
plus sous pression ce lié à
d'éventuelles malversations disant mot
ou co procédure judiciaire en cours
contre le front national et les niveaux
européens sans eau de ger le
parlementaire oui c'est vrai qu'il ya 5
millions d'euros en jeu quand même donc
ces drames l'un la somme que réclame de
fête parlement européen bon mais je
pense c'est un autre dossier cette
histoire du parlement européen en
revanche que ce qui est possible c'est
une spéculation ce qui est possible
c'est que c'est que la banque en
l'occurrence général et un doute encore
une fois je redis sur la carre l'origine
des noms mais en manquant peut-être même
davantage sur la capacité de
l'emprunteur à rembourser et a fortiori
sachant que dans le même temps post
législatives les usines var du front
national ont diminué puisque puisque
recul recul électoral sur législatives
donc donc du coup j'ai cinq cent mille
euros
moi c'est ça et c'est à peu près
doutes sur la capacité à rembourser vous
ne sentez pas d'emprunt vous ne fermez
pas les comptes c'est pas tout à fait
même chose radi c'est assez radical
c'est radical mais après des mois de
débats donc oui mais pas si ryan st
juste le trésorier du front national dit
on nous a jamais demandé de précision
sur l'origine de nos de nos virement de
déplacement donc une hypothèse tracfin
en tout cas il a des manques puisque si
c'était le cas on peut supposer que la
banque aurait demandé ces précisions
donc ça paraît pas très nettes et deux
dans la mesure où l'affairé sur la place
publique
je trouve qu'il serait il serait bien
que la banque ses souliers sur les
motivations
oui c'est l'image de la société générale
le fait d'être la banque entre
guillemets du front national c'était une
personne ne le savait maintenant oui
c'est vrai c'est plutôt ça s'évalue
nuire j'en sais rien la cité général et
pas dans une forme resplendissante en ce
moment compliqué à dire je crois que
quand on est dans un système de
dédiabolisation du front national lens
qui n'en depuis des années gires les
gens se cachent plus pour dire qu'ils
votent fn jean quoi aujourd'hui ça
serait une targue d'être la banque des
faits c'est naturel que le parti qui
arrive en deuxième position à la
présidentielle est une banque ça
pourtant pas renoncé et soleil qu'une
banques aujourd'hui soient bien gérer
parce que depuis qu'on a vécu la crise
de 2008 on attend on attend d'une banque
qu'elle soit bien gérée du coup les
arguments moi je suis peut-être
minoritaires l'attention ce plateau mais
les arguments sur la question de la
capacité de remboursement est l'origine
des fonds je trouve qu'ils ont un sens
développé
je veux dire c'est que la société serait
bien même d'image si elle s'est
développée sur des arguments techniques
auprès de le disons qu'en refusant de
s'exprimer sur les motivations de cette
décision la société générale ne fait que
entretenir une forme de succès
il est vrai aussi de dire que le front
national n'est pas le seul parti à avoir
des difficultés à obtenir des emprunts
auprès des banques enfin moi je vais
vous raconter une anecdote personnelle
en en septembre 2000 il ya un an donc
emmanuel macron lancé sa campagne
d'accord bon il cherche peux vous dire
qu'il cherchait des fonds oui et donc se
sont pas pressés d'aller poser même
j'aurais attendu de voir si le truc
mordait quoi voilà et quand elles ont
senti que c'était en train de m'en ben
là il a obtenu ce qu'il voulait parce
que baron prête alors comme une forme
prête enfin j'avais durant près de
corinne on ne prête qu'aux riches mais
mais ça facilite et au début et même
tout emmanuel macron qu'il était comme
on savait pas trop où ça allait bon les
banques à regarder ça d'un oeil un petit
peu oui bonjour rien encore il s'agit
car c'étaient des millions qui est des
temps je garde il n'était pas certain de
pouvoir se lancer dans la campagne
d'exal en ciel parce qu'il lui manquait
encore au moment où c'est devenu très
sérieuse 50% des fonds nécessaires pour
pouvoir faire campagne mais pas celle
d'accorder les autres huiles et sous la
neige que vous ne savez pas ce qui fit
les pas l'apartheid
oui mais pas de parti n'est pas de
structure il partait de zéro et on sait
qu'ils apprennent à l'eau glacée des
banques pareil mais non mais non mais la
question des banques parce que tout est
une grosse banque il ya eu la question
des donateurs qui a quand même été agité
pendant toute la campagne par certains
adversaires des manuels macron
vous avez derrière v max non mais
c'était intéressant parce que comme il
était pris nouveau nom mais comme il
était qu'au niveau laquelle il posait il
amener à poser des questions nouvelles
parce que sinon on a toujours l'argent
public qui en fait permet d'amorcer dès
lors d'un party wii qui lui mais qu'elle
a financé par de longs publié d'argent
que l'occurrence il n'avait pas de parti
dont qu'il a fait mais qu'il a cherché
comme dirait l'autre avec les dents
l'argent nécessaire pour pouvoir dire
quand ce n'était pas de l'argent public
sur le chat du figaro tassadar nous dit
est ce que le npa où la france a
soumises ont les mêmes problèmes c'est
un peu les la question effectivement
conso vécu tellement selon petit parisy
et ont des problèmes avec leurs banques
eet la discussion est extrêmement serré
avec la banque et et que les choses se
sont durcies depuis quelques années
parce que les banques sont plus
prudentes elles sont plus prudentes
elles ont peut-être davantage elle-même
de garantie à donner et puis c'est
exactement ce qu'on vient de dire elle
parie sur ce qu'ils vont déjà gagnants
font c'est qu'ils vont gagner donc elles
sont en général pas très pionnière sur
le fait de prononcer quelques mots loto
un 100% des gagnants ont tenté leur
chance alors on va parler d'un tout
autre sujet c'est celui de ce stage très
spécial on va dire que le syndicat sud
éducation de seine saint denis propose
aux enseignants
une initiative qui a d'ailleurs été
dévoilée par le figaro ce matin les
ateliers de ce stage sont proposés en
non mixité traduire ils sont interdits
aux blancs et ce stage annoncé löw sic
en écriture inclusive affiche complet
les thèmes de réflexion sont
à l'avenant on parle de racisme d'état
dans l'éducation nationale de postures
dominante des enseignants blanc et on
s'interroge sur la vie professionnelle
des enseignants racisées alors le
ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer a réagi dès hier ils l'estiment
que tout ceci est inconstitutionnelle et
inacceptable
c'était ce qu'il a postées sur twitter
jean-marc four il faut interdire un tel
stage c'est vrai que ce truc est assez
vertigineux quand même voir nauséabond
mais surtout j'irais même jusqu'à dire
contre-productif aussi parce que c'est
quand même étrange on prétend dénoncer
le racisme la discrimination et pour ce
faire on fait de la discrimination c'est
quand même tout à fait surprenant cet
après midi d'ailleurs jean michel
blanquer ou city son tweet là mais a été
ovationnée à l'assemblée nationale lors
des questions au gouvernement sur ce
sujet maintenant s'il estime que c'est
inconstitutionnel alors ben il faut mais
alors tu es en justice
on va je pose la question globalement
interdiction qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
oui non là on en est que je ne connais
pas l'état du droit sur cette question
ce qui me paraît évident c'est que
on a effectivement on assiste un
phénomène détenait d'ethnie that you
station le sens diction avec lui il
avait un très fort de la société
française qui provient légèrement des
mouvements antiracistes et ce sont les
prétendent lutter contre le racisme qui
ramène tout à la race et qui de fait
raciste comme ils disent
parce qu'on avait eu le camp d'été des
colonials on a eu les ateliers de
defensa fans amassés par exemple comme
un séminaire de formation mais c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'extrêmement
mais on sait que derrière toutes les
questions qui sont posées sont des
conclusions c'est à dire qu'on a on a
quelque chose extrêmement militants sur
affirmant que l'état est raciste que
d'un certain nombre de composés prendre
que le ministre de l'éducation nationale
sans s'en offusquer ses skis et ski est
très compliqué c'est que c'est tellement
ridicule absurde on a même l'impression
d'être dans le monde vraiment de
l'absurde x a fait oublier qu'il ya des
problèmes réels moi c'est ça c'est là
que j'ai envie de réagir c'est à dire
que je regardais d'ailleurs je trouve
que je connais une des intervenantes
joyel nacira guénif là sur le quai une
jeune femme que je connais de longue
date qui est très bien je sais pas
comment ces personnes peuvent se
retrouver là dedans c'est je ne suis pas
sûr même que ceux qui ont qui sont
intervenants et la wii la défiance de là
où ils mettent les pieds ou de la
présentation militante qui est fait et
ça fait oublier les discriminations
territoriales les discriminations
raciales qui sont très forts dans notre
pays et je me disais mais comment est-ce
qu'on s'est inscrit à ce stage c'est à
dire que c'est bien gentil de dire que
c'est interdit aux non blancs c'est
pardon c'est interdit aux blancs mais le
sujet c'est alors on est sélectionné sur
le nom sur la tête sur une photo le
stage pour être précis oui mais tout le
stage qui intéresse les sags la 16e
session des ateliers
non blancs il y en avait il y en a aussi
dans certaines facultés moi j'ai déjà vu
afficher atteler non blancs à l'occasion
de grève étudiante dans certaines
facultés donc ça existe en fait d'assez
longue date et là et là ça moins un
mérite c'est qu'on met le projecteur là
dessus parce que c'est justement une
formation organisée par les syndicats
ils font pas quand même prendre un peu
de naïveté parce que quand on regarde et
qu'on s'intéresse un peu à la question
il ya la présence de monsieur qui a été
longtemps aux commandes du ccf le comité
contre l'islamophobie le collectif
marwan al mabhouh et donc on sait que
c'est pas totalement non plus sorti de
nulle part quoi c'est pas juste des
profs qui se réunissaient pas sûr que
tous ceux qui sont se sont inscrits
connaissait les noms des intervenants
enfin bon moi je je je sais pas je sais
pas qui était inscrit d'ailleurs et
marquer complet oui la journaliste
figaro qu'est-ce exactement et ce qui
est une manière face qu'il faudrait
c'est interroger ceux qui se sont
inscrits quelque part aussi parce que je
pense que quelques on peut aller là
dedans avec une certaine bonne foi c'est
ça que je veux dire après je ne
défendrai pas le jeu ne défendrait pas
les jeux termine juste que j'ai à dire
mais mon sentiment c'est que les
problèmes qui sont décrits sont assez
réelle avec des mots délirants je suis
d'accord mais il faut pas oublier aussi
la réalité de ces difficultés et c'est
ce stage risque de renforcer le
sentiment qu'au fond on est bien entre
français blanc on raconte bien notre
histoire alors que c'est évidemment l'un
vers ce qu'il faut faire
marc-andré quand on connaît les origines
de sud éducation leur idéologie leurs
pensées leurs discours c'est des actions
pas surprenant vous dites qui s'inscrit
à ces stages là sont des stages d'un
syndicat sur des questions qui sont des
stages de formation qui sont à la marge
des questions d'éducation ce sont des
militants sont des militants qui
partagent la même idéologie que le
syndicat pour lequel ils votent dont
lequel il adhère donc bien souvent eux
ne sont pas surpris ne sont pas choqués
encore faut-il qu'ils aient exactement
connaissance des intitulés d un autre
mais sur la philosophie générale ils
sont d'accord
sud éducation c'est quoi ce sont les
anciens sont les anciens
autogestionnaire de la cfdt c'est les
plus durs de durs de l'ancien cfdt quand
il ya eu le virage qui a été fait sur on
en arrête l'autogestion ce sont les plus
dures de chez solidaires qui sont quand
même les plus réactionnaires ou du moins
les plus
anti capitalistes les plus mondialiste
du monde syndical aujourd'hui c'est pas
c'est simplement un constat
donc il n'ya pas y'a rien de surprenant
dans ce que fait aujourd'hui
sud éducation quand on sait d'où ils
viennent et dont on sait quand on
connaît l'idéologie qu'il prône enfin je
trouve cela les bagarres il faut le
préciser est fort minoritaire dans
l'éducation
mais là où ses dires est limité où le
bât blesse encore plus c'est que ces
formations où ces pseudos formation et
je mets de multiples guillemets autour
du mot formations sont faits sur le
temps de travail
ouï dire qu'en plus des allées ont pas
cours auront se poser la question au
début de faut-il interdire de façon un
petit peu abrupte mais d'après ce que
racontent les 20 ans du figaro qui est
sorti le sujet
ça fait partie de la formation il n'y a
pas tellement de moyens d'empêcher un
enseignant d'y aller ils sont posés la
question autour de jean-michel bancaire
et ça fait partie de la liberté
syndicale
j'ai même pas s'arrêter à d'autres
formations et des côtes informations qui
sont obligatoires donc ce stage est
discriminatoire c'est à dire que moi je
pense je sais pas s'il est
anticonstitutionnelle je pense qu'il est
en tout cas illégal parce qu'il est
discriminatoire c'est à dire qu'on
interdit aux gens de s'y inscrire en
raison de la couleur de leur peau
donc il est à mon avis profondément
illégal il a exigé que ce n'est pas très
étonnant venant de sud ceci étant je
suis pas sûr qu'ils auraient mis en
avant des thématiques comme ça il ya
quelques années on sent quand même qu'à
une progression de ces dossiers
thématiques il ya une infiltration de
mouvements d'extrême gauche dans des
institutions diverses pour faire
progresser cette thématique d'accusation
systématique de notre histoire et de
notre identité et que c'est quelque
chose qui était en train de monter en
puissance d'internet ramène à la
révision la servir l'histoire de france
d'amour sur un sou dessous des questions
sur des questions insiste c'est pas
nouveau non parce que par exemple si on
relit quelqu'un comme todorov qui est
qui nous a quittés ya pas très longtemps
c'était un de ces sujets principaux de
recherche
il a quand même fait des travaux très
intéressant sur notre ethnocentrisme
dans nos programmes qui sont des travaux
qui sont pas tellement contesté enfin je
veux dire
regardons c'est à la découverte de
l'amérique voilà un exemple facile a
donc on ne voit que du point de vue de
christophe colomb et il ya des indigènes
sur place si on le regarde jamais du
côté des gens qui habitaient et là avant
qu'on y arrive qu'elles ont à nouveau
serré de large qui consiste à dire les
blancs vous allez à ce lait dans cet
atelier où la seule chose que vous aurez
le droit de dire c'est à quel point vous
êtes pu battre nadal
c'est comme radicalement et idiot dans
cette histoire c'est que ça fait oublier
tous les progrès qu'on a fait sur la
relecture de l'histoire de france c'est
à dire que moi je vais dire raconte des
histoires personnelles moi j'ai été
élevé en nouvelle calédonie je me
rappelle d'avoir appris nos ancêtres les
gaulois ou en kanaky
donc on a fait énormément de progrès de
piste il ya fort longtemps mais il ya
quelque chose autour de cette révision
qu'on a réussi à faire et là on dirait
quelque part qu'on est accusé de quelque
chose alors que le processus a été
plutôt extrêmement positif dans
l'éducation nationale
j'ai bien lu les thèmes des ateliers
aussi c'est pas uniquement la question
des programmes c'est aussi une question
que de fait il faut probablement abordée
c'est le personnel éducatif face à ses
clients c'est à dire les élèves et vous
avez quand même à certains endroits il
faut regarder sujet aussi en face vous
avez parlons le dire mais allons-y je
veux dire jeune professeur blanc face à
une clientèle de d'enfants qui eux sont
de toutes ethnies content de lui et qui
le voient et oui ça me parle et qu'il
vous qui le voit qui le voient comme un
blanc non je dis juste qu'on peut pas
joindre une histoire de france je suis
pas laissé jean marc pujol à part
l'absence d'un sujet qu'il faut regarder
parce que de fait je pense que le propos
de l'enseignant est polluée par le fait
qu'il est perçue d'abord comme étant
blancs et c'est une problématique dans
un certain nombre de quartiers c'est une
vérité voilà une fois que vous êtes posé
la question n'est pas la réponse qu'il
faut pas mettre la poussière sous cette
absence il faut il faut lutter contre le
fait que un discours commun n'est plus
audible par personne et quand justement
on essaye de fragments tel discours pour
le rendre audible par les différentes
communautés ça c'est le truc contre
lequel il faut lutter de manière
absolument priorités et jean michel
blanc coeur mon avis si at-elle de
bagnères mais ce qui est important c'est
que les attentes à la façon d'un surnom
de professeur quand il a fallu observer
la minute de silence et ses dix ans nous
allons nous a confié une mission
impossible donc moi je trouve que ce qui
est peut-être qu'on peut tirer un truc
positif de cette énorme connerie c'est
se repencher candide faut lutter certes
faut lutter mais comment est-ce qu'on le
fait concrètement et comment est-ce
qu'on amène les professeurs avec des cas
pratiques à comprendre
comment se comporter vis-à-vis des
élèves la diversité des classes enfin
mon avis on est pas on est ce sont des
vrais qu'est ce que tu vois là je vais
donner la parole l'accueillir jean
baptiste et mrdja qui nous a rejoint
jean baptiste jeu bien plus en jeu merci
un peu tôt les non seulement des cours
de diction mais aussi des cours de
de marque c'est un tollé ou pas cette
histoire de d'ateliers racisées ou pas
oui beaucoup de critiques quand même en
ligne beaucoup de critiques mais aussi
certaines sphères de twitter qui est
dans un soutien s'il ya vraiment une
opposition nous sommes de ce fait à
idéologie qui s'opposent contrées pour
mais après faut aussi se dire que ces
ateliers ne date pas d'hier ils ont une
date d'il ya un mois ça a été publiée à
peu près en 19 octobre pas le syndicat
sud
c'est le militant socialiste nassim
seddiki qui a sorti ça vendredi dernier
ensuite naturellement il ya eu un buzz
comme on dit c'est à dire beaucoup de
gens se sont révélés pour aux comptes
comme on expliquer tout à l'heure la
ligue internationale contre le racisme
et l'antisémitisme licra était une des
premières à réagir en disant nous
refusons d'en d'étiqueter les enfants
des écoles de la république et leurs
enseignants en fonction de leurs
critères dins est digne d'une exposition
coloniale ils y vont quand même assez
fort bon j'ai essayé de revenir un petit
peu sur un événement qui nous a
peut-être tous marqués sur le même sujet
c'était les commissions non mixtes de
nuit debout en 2016 et à cette époque
les féministes les militantes féministes
expliquer cette mixité par la non mixité
est un outil d'émancipation politique
par la libération de la parole des
populations dominées via un espace de
non confrontation directe avec le groupe
dominant ça va pas mal plus en tout cas
ça convainc et ça permet de comprendre
un peu plus que le oui non ils refusent
ces racialisée cd racialisée et ses
expressions des blancs est forcément
oppresseurs donc on n'a qu'un droit
c'est soutenons mais ça revient à les
dominer qui est intéressant en tout cas
on comprend mieux que attention c'est
que pour les blancs c'est que pour les
noirs s'adonne clinique tout va bien
mais la différence c'est que là c'est
des commissions débat tandis que là
c'est des trucs de formation donc je
trouve que c'est une différence de
nature aussi moi j'ai eu des discussions
avec yvette roudy quand j'étais au parti
socialiste parce qu'elle voulait qu'on
fasse des réunions où il y avait surtout
pas les hommes est jeune et c'était plus
intéressant d'y goûter
elle disait non on fera ça quand on sera
plus forte donc c'est un les arguments
des organisateurs lire ça libère la
parole tron il ya le
4-1 différentes tous les hommes sont
différents je vous rassure c'est jean
baptiste
l'argument liste était que si un
ensemble de femmes débattent sur le
féminisme avec des hommes la vie des
hommes va gagner en tout cas la position
l'opinion des remises alors l'opinion
des désordres à gagner sur le présent
des femmes donc c'est pour ça qu'il
voulait avoir une non mixité ce qui est
enfin en tout cas c'est qu'on prend
ainsi que ça apporte à un lien et de
compréhension qu'on n'a pas spécialement
je finis en disant que sud a réagi hier
avec un communiqué de presse
oui critique surtout leur ministre enfin
le ministre création du sénat qui est
aussi leur ministre actuellement nous
apprécierons qu'au lieu de se calquer
sur son âge un son agenda sur français
de souche
d'autres ministres et les organisations
qui se réclament de l'égalité
républicaine s'intéresse au manque de
moyens dont souffre l'école et nos
élèves
il conclut en disant que c'est complet
ça rejoint un petit peu aussi ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure qui en voilà
effectivement c'est un sujet de fond
mais il ya au delà de ça le manque de
moyens je dirais en disant comme disait
coluche dans le maître d'école en 80
être syndiqués ne dispense pas d'être
intelligent ça c'est pour sud éducation
merci pour ce bout de la fin un dernier
mot quand même le stage l'intitulé été
rédigée en écriture inclusive écriture
inclusive dont le premier ministre a
fait savoir aujourd'hui qu'il ne voulait
plus la voir dans les documents
officiels réaction rapide on a déjà le
souvent parler de ce sujet sur ce
plateau
moi j'allais dire faut pas que
l'opposition l'écriture inclusive
devienne le fait qu'on n'est que de la
novlangue c'est à dire de la langue
officielle ça me rassure pas que doit
philippe dit ça après l'écriture
inclusive je suis plutôt je trouve ça
compliqué mais je trouve que ce cette
espèce de haro contre l'écriture
inclusive est aussi une manière de
refermer des débats qu'il faudrait
peut-être ouvrir sur qui s'approprie
l'orthographe la question des inégalités
scolaires etc
l'écriture française est compliqué
laurent dandrieu je ne tiens absolument
la proposition d'edouard philippe c'est
un clé l'écriture inclusive c'est un
élément de brouillage de brouillage
absolue des repères une époque qui n'a
vraiment pas besoin de ça le combat pour
l'égalité il passe par l'écriture
inclusive ce n'est pas une décision
surprenante de la part d'un petit lob de
voir on
on a même des bas voilà on a revu les
termes du débat cette décision est sans
surprise et en même temps une demi-heure
enfin je veux dire vous voyez favorable
à la féminisation des noms de métiers
des fonctions marc-andré un dernier mot
je suis patient coluche là dessus non
non je sais par contre c'est que les
prémunit je suis pour la féminisation
des métiers par contre c'est imbécile
futur et que vous souhaitiez vous des
métiers alors c'est une femme à la tête
de paris la maire de paris c'est un
nouveau scud on va dire un rapport
dénicher aussi pour le figaro très
critique sur les conséquences de la
fermeture des voûtes de la voie sur
berge aux voitures une piétonnisation
qui entraînait plus d'embouteillages
plus de pollution selon ces experts qui
ont travaillé pour la région ile de
france
mais valérie pécresse la présidente de
la région et les républicains d'ailleurs
en général ne s'empare pas vraiment de
la question alors lucile schmid
finalement si on est vraiment écolo il
faut revenir sur cette fermeture des
voies sur berge
expliquez-nous en trois mots je sens que
vous avez envie de déclencher une
polémique mais écouter non il faut pas
revenir là-dessus après moi je voulais
dire une chose pour défendre anne
hidalgo une petite chose c'est que c'est
difficile quand on fait de la politique
de voir les choses à 10 15 ans c'est à
dire que je pense qu'elle a de manière
assez forte et en prenant la suite de
bertrand delanoë décidé que l'écologie
était une vraie question politique
d'ailleurs elles sont nées en paraît en
prenant la tête d'une association des
maires de grandes villes au niveau
mondial dont elles portent quelque chose
et avec une vision après la difficulté
sur les voies sur berge c'est qu'on voit
qu'on est partie prenante d'assystem et
ça m'étonne pas valérie pécresse soit
pas emparés du sujet politiquement pour
lancer un scud parce qu'elle sait bien
que c'est compliqué la circulation c'est
à dire on vient à paris en voiture parce
qu'on veut continuer à venir en voiture
ou qu'on peut pas faire autrement il ya
des motivations très différentes et il
ya un problème de transport en commun
c'est à dire que quand on aura le grand
paris express peut-être qu'on aura moins
de voitures donc la question c'est
comment on se projette dans l'avenir et
pour l'instant c'est sûr que c'est pas
une grande réussite
mais je pense que on peut essayer de se
dire qu'on est peut-être un point
d'étape qui n'est pas très favorable et
je voulais quand même ajouter une chose
c'est que on a fait les choses peut-être
pas dans le bon ordre
là pour le coup je gens vers un petit
scud année
i'll go à londres on a fait des grands
parkings et en bordure de londres on a
fait du péage urbain
donc en fait interdire dévoue à la
circulation ça fait partie d'un système
de mesure et je pense que là on a fait
un truc qui est très sympa pour les
parisiens qui habite à côté c'est super
et on n'a pas pensé grand paris donc on
a un sujet on pense le grand londres
nous on pense pas assez le grand paris
c'était quoi c'était le côté symbolique
leur entente c'est pas très sympa et du
deuxième partie de ma question c'est
effectivement pourquoi la droite ne
s'empare pas les gêner aux entournures
avec cette histoire de comprendre c'est
un rapport qui a été commandé par classe
mais un général sur ce sujet on ne peut
pas dire que la droite monte vraiment au
créneau le plan adopté à l'unanimité
hier à au conseil de paris
voilà c'est pas c'est pas un sujet de
vraiment de bataille qu elle enfourche à
fleurs à droite oui oui il n'aurait plus
le lidar y at il une droite encore c'est
une vraie question
moi ce que je trouve un peu effrayant
cette affaire c'est que on a
l'impression qu'on pourrait accumuler
tous les rapports possibles aussi
négatif soit il anne hidalgo en fait
s'en fout parce que c'est son but c'est
pas de modifier le réel son but c'est un
but purement idéologique c'est de
dégoûter les gens bien la limite plus
c'est le bazar plus elle est contente
parce que elle veut dégoûter les gens de
la voiture plus c'est le bazar plus est
content tu veux dégoûter les gens mais
oui je suis tout à fait d'accord je
pense effectivement qu'elle va dégoûter
les gens absolument
mais après on peut être d'accord avec
elles vont désaccord mais on peut être
d'accord aussi avec elle a estimé
qu'elle a raison de vouloir dégoûter les
gens c'est sale c'est en fait le sujet
là si vous les siècles que le rapport
soit accablant mais c'est plus dur plus
c'est dur mais c'est logique que le
rapport soit accablant voilà et c'est à
dire que ben oui évidemment les en
bouteille les gens continuent à prendre
leur voiture donc qu'est ce qui s'est
passé il ya plus embouteillages sur les
zones où au lieu qui est 4 doigts il y
en a 2 etc
et puis la pollution qui étaient là au
lieu qu'elle soit d'un côté elle est
passée de l'autre bon bah oui d'accord
cqfd
c'est absolument sans surprise après la
question de la vraie question politique
derrière c'est effectivement de savoir
si elle a raison de vouloir d'écouter
les gens voilà c'est ça le sujet et on
en a parlé déjà une fois ici je me
souviens donc la vraie question c'est
quelles conséquences dire ton de ce tir
de rapports et encore une fois il ya
deux il ya deux options soit on dit faut
arrêter parce que vraiment c'est
n'importe quoi soit on dit il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin et je pense que là ni
d'allouer sur la deuxième position parce
qu'effectivement elle estime
en tout cas je pense de bonne foi quand
elle dit ça que à 10 ou 15 ans c'est
dans l'intérêt supérieur
l'intérêt général que d'aller encore
plus loin voilà mais après je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec ce que dit avant
c'est à dire que ça n'a pas été pensée
globale pour connaître un peu londres ça
va être dépensé davantage global
effectivement si dans le même temps vous
n'avez pas un plan plus général sur
allez on double le nombre de bus on
multiplie par cinq le nombre de vélos
etc etc
vous ne montrez pas parce que les gens
continuent à prendre leur voiture donc
on va continuer de s'empaler dans des
bouchons qui vont ne sait s'ils ne vont
cesser de croître
marc landré vous qui êtes soucieux de
notre santé c'est un argument souvent
employée par anne hidalgo en disant un
jour on nous fera un procès parce qu'on
n'aura pas pris soin suffisamment de la
santé de nos concitoyens
en ce sens les d'un oui c'est un an
c'est sûr que la pollution ça tu sais je
sais tautologique monsieur de la palice
n'aurait pas dit autre chose et comme
dit jean marc le fait de déplacer les
voitures d'un point a vers un point b on
déplace la pollution d'un point pour un
1er mai ceci dit que les grandes
métropoles internationales et donc paris
fait partie soit des villes polluées
avec des risques pour les enfants
notamment
et pour les personnes âgées ça se sait
il suffit de prendre par exemple
autrement que sur des questions de 2,2
purement de pollution du moins liés à la
circulation
vous prenez les pics de police des pics
de l'epic de canicule qui sont aggravés
par les questions de circulation
je veux dire qu'ils sont les premiers à
en souffrir ce sont les jeunes et les
personnes âgées
donc oui que à terme ça a une incidence
sur la santé et que ça puisse avoir une
incidence ou une conséquence pénale bien
sûr mais je ne suis pas sûr que ça soit
la première des finalités pensé par
bernard non mais là c'est même pourquoi
ce que souligner le sujet mais pourquoi
elle a ça dans cet ordre là pourquoi pas
d'abord avancé sur un plan ce que c'est
bouchra paris c'était beaucoup plus
simple c'est une question de gros sous
non si tu penses que c'est une question
de ces de la région pour terminer le
court termisme effectivement pour des
questions de ralliement peut-être d'une
partie de la cause écologique il fallait
prendre des décisions radicales tout de
suite elle n'avait pas le temps
forcément de penser un schéma beaucoup
plus grand et compris qu'elle devait
négocier avec des territoires ou des
collectivités
départements et trois régions et
franchement je veux dire c'est il faut
être un chat pour ceux ne pas voir ne
pas savoir qu'entre anne hidalgo et
valérie pécresse je veux dire c'est pas
l'amour fou
donc c'est compliqué même si avant
d'aller pécresse était une majorité
socialiste qui dirigeait la région et
qu'il aurait été plus simple de
s'accorder avec elle mais il y avait des
rivalités politiques entre bertrand
delanoë et jean paul huchon qui ont
aussi rendu difficile le fait de pouvoir
établir un plan au niveau régional parce
qu'on raisonne pas grand paris en fait
c'est à dire on ne pouvait pas y avait
pas la métropole là pour le coup moi je
suis pour la métropole parce que ça
permet d'avoir un territoire où on
pourrait justement raisonner comme le
grand londres
et puis la deuxième chose c'est que il
faut pas inverser les choses c'est quand
même pas anne hidalgo qui fait les gens
prennent leur voiture il ya aussi dans
la transition écologique à une
transition
il ya une transition mentale en fête
culturelle donc lorsqu'on vit non je
crois pas qu'ils aient toujours un
besoin je crois que j'en écoute et je ne
crois pas de santé dans les
embouteillages sont échauffés non je
crois pas je crois que ça dépend des
gens je l' ai dit tout à l'heure je
crois qu'il ya effectivement des
obligations économiques pour certains
pour les artisans pour certains
commerçants mais je crois qu'ils aient
aussi des gens qui préfèrent tout seuls
dans leur voiture comme une bulle de
confort pour écouter leurs radios et que
les transports en commun c'est souvent
un peu compliqué quand le rer à des
difficultés et c'est donc je crois qu'il
ya un mélange et que quelque part quand
on veut être un un politique qui a une
vision il faut affronter les conflits et
que ça nous fait pas de mal aussi de
nous apercevoir que parfois le court
termisme électorale peut être combattu
avec des mesures qui on verra dans dix
ans moi je voulais juste dire juste une
petite chose il ya eu je termine il ya
une commission au sénat sur la pollution
de l'air et rappelez vous il ya quand
même un grand professeur de médecine qui
en même temps a été consultant pour
total qui a osé dire que la pollution de
l'air ne causait pas de cancer
bon il a été condamné et on prend petit
à petit des mesures on s'aperçoit qu'il
ya des choses importantes on est aussi
dans un moment où on découvre des choses
qui n'étaient pas dit auparavant donc il
faut prendre le risque de dire des
choses nouvelles et parfois de d'avoir
de nouveaux conflits avec des personnes
qui veulent toujours prendre la voiture
y compris pour des raisons de confort
impérativement besoin de leur voiture
tout à fait exact il y en a aussi un
certain nombre qui la prennent pas
habitude culturelle puisque dans l'est
et dans les agglomérations cm x qu'à peu
près un tiers des trajets qu'ils sont
étrangers
moins de trois kilomètres de moins de 3
kilomètres
est-ce qu'on peut décerner des bons
points dire oui les artisans ok mais pas
celui qui a envie de travailler dans
faster et à ceux des villes qui sont
prises qui sont professionnellement
plusieurs il ya encore dix ans ils
objectent se déplacer clio milliards
dont on peut changer les habitudes
changent on les essais non respectons
les obligations professionnelles j'ai
pas de voiture bon eh ben c'est une info
comme une autre merci marc merci à tous
les quatre on n'aura pas eu le fin mot
de l'histoire sur le remaniement attendu
un pronostic n'ont pas vu cela comme ça
non bon et son fils et et et on me dit
l'info de la soirée qui nous emmène un
peu plus loin c'est que mugabe
démissionne alors que huit présidente
ondimba bruit merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre est resté sur figaro lie figaro
live où vous avez marie-laëtitia
bonavita qui reçoit le chercheur aux
historiens du cnrs pierre jean luizard
pierre jean luizard pour son passionnant
livre décryptage sur les gens jeu des
rivalités entre sunnites et chiites au
moyen-orient et à demain pour un nouveau
point de vue présentée par guillaume
roquette
[Musique]